good morning John this is a QR code it's
a way of visually representing data just
like barcodes or snap codes or facial
expressions or the written word and I
was looking at one of these things
recently I thought to myself how much
data could you really fit on a QR code
well QR codes are complicated and I
don't have enough time to explain them
in total but suffice to say that each
block of two by four squares codes for
one byte of data one character of text
question I had was could you print out
all of Wikipedia on one QR code and have
a camera that could scan that code and
then you could get all of Wikipedia just
by scanning one QR code I'm aware that
this is a dumb question but it is the
kind of dumb question that I very much
enjoy figuring out the answer to just
the text portions of just the English
portion of Wikipedia it's about 24
terabytes
that's 24 trillion bytes and so in order
to get the number of squares we need we
just multiply that by 8 because it's 8
squares per byte I don't really want to
know how many squares this thing's gonna
be I want to know how many squares it's
going to be on each side so we take the
square root of that number figure out
how much actual space that will take up
we have to figure out how big each one
of those tiny little blocks is I'm gonna
say about 2 millimeters because that's
pretty easy to both print and to read
for a QR code reader you multiply that
number by 2 and then convert from
millimeters to kilometers and there you
have it you have a QR code that's just
27 kilometers on a side that has all of
Wikipedia on it and of course this is
just half the battle we've printed out
Wikipedia on a 27 kilometer by 27
kilometer sheet of paper but we need a
camera that can actually read that well
if you have a camera with a 90 degree
field of view then you can take a
picture of this whole thing you just
have to be 13.5 kilometers away from it
however there's some bad news that comes
along with this first at that distance
the Earth's atmosphere is going to
distort this image way too much so we
got to take it out of the atmosphere in
into space put the QR code on the
surface of the Moon and put the camera
in orbit around the moon at around 13.5
kilometers up
nobody second problem is actually a
bigger problem because it deals with
video just sort of the fundamental
nature of the universe from so far away
and with blocks so tiny to try and
resolve you run into what's called the
diffraction limit basically when passing
through the aperture of our camera the
difference between the size of our
aperture that's the hole that the light
comes through and the wavelength of
light is significant enough that it
blurs anything below a certain size so
to take a picture of something so tiny
from so far away you need
to do one of two things or both of them
one make the aperture of the camera
really huge or to make the wavelength of
the light smaller but if you want to
take the picture of this thing with a
cell phone cam you can as long as your
cell phone camera just happens to be
able to detect gamma rays gamma rays are
radiation with very small wavelength
also problematically with very high
energy so it's difficult to print with
ink that would absorb gamma rays because
they would normally just fly right
through it so you got to find some kind
of really special gamma ray absorbing
ink the other in my opinion better
solution to this problem is to make your
aperture just huge and one way to do
that is to just use the James Webb Space
Telescope which we're already developing
and has a pretty massive aperture I'd
have to modify it so it could be a wider
angle camera because it's a telescope
right it's got telescopic not a wide
angle lens but the James Webb Space
Telescope does have an aperture big
enough that it could conceivably resolve
these two millimeter pixel things from
13.5 kilometers away however it does not
have a sensor sensitive enough to take a
picture of all of them at once which I
would like for it to do so that we could
just take a picture real quick have ala
Wikipedia so we are going to have to
develop a new camera sensor that has
like 10,000 times more pixel resolution
than the current highest and military
spy cameras that we use but I have
confidence that we can do that in the
intervening time between when we are
able to actually print out all these
pieces of paper which is going to take
some time and get them to the moon and
lay them out in the proper order so the
answer the question can you print out
Wikipedia and I have it be a scannable
QR code the answer is yes not really
with current technology but it is
possible John I will see you on Tuesday
I want to end this video by saying you
know I'm not entirely sure I could have
got something wrong and I want to say
thanks to Henry from minutephysics for
coming over and helping me with the math
for all this it was a really enjoyable
project that's my life